we're back to uh um skype team zoom
whatever you want to call it
everything what should we talk about
today then i was watching um a video
by richard mortier on secure web stuff
right so
sort of tls bit of certificates and
things and i thought it might be a good
time to
revisit this issue of tls right what is
it
you know what's ssl what's tls where did
it come from
um because it's it's everywhere i was
going to
attempt to remember what it what tls
stands for uh
transport layer service close but no
uh transport layer security you got two
two or three
it's absolutely everywhere it'll be
being used for the for the communication
we're doing right now
it's going to be used when you go on the
web to upload this to youtube you know
and so on and so forth right it's used
it's used everywhere um but that wasn't
always the case right if you went
if you go back to you know the mid 90s
very little
on the internet was encrypted at all um
and maybe at that time it wasn't quite
so important because there was fewer
people on the internet for a start
and we did less stuff like online
banking online shopping
things like this there were less there
were fewer credit card details flying
over the place
that we want to try and keep an eye on
um but that is not the case anymore
right now
we kind of have come to actually expect
that everything is encrypted
and when it's not big warnings start to
show which is not you know didn't used
to be the case
um so actually this goes this goes way
back sort of
sort of to the mid and early 90s right
so at that time
netscape were using their netscape
navigator browser i actually managed to
install it on a windows 98
virtual machine the other day it took me
back a bit a few people you know the nsa
had been looking at this
netscape had been looking at this other
groups have been looking at this idea of
web encryption
um and they'd all come at it from
different ways and you have a problem
when everyone comes out starting
something from a different direction
that you end up with loads of competing
protocols that don't
work together and and maybe none of me
end up getting used
right so there was definitely a
consensus that
something needed to be done about web
encryption but
there was no kind of way forward so yeah
i fired up um
both internet explorer five would you
believe and uh
and netscape navigator three i think
neither of which work on the majority of
websites anymore because
thankfully these websites tell us to get
lost because we don't have
sufficient security right you know
there's fewer websites that support only
http now those kind of load but then
javascript turns up and everything goes
a bit wrong so it was quite a fun
experience um i got
uh to use the web archive to look
through some old bbc
articles you know in in very grainy
graphics i mean it's worth bearing in
mind but there was very little on the
web in the early 90s right so in fact it
didn't really matter once amazon appears
in other online shops suddenly
we've got a real need for this if you
recall very brief recap right
um when you send a request to a website
and
just for now we'll talk only about
websites but of course actually tls
applies to a lot of other stuff as well
you're going to be sending http messages
right so
these http messages you know http get
http response things like this
this payload is going to be put inside a
tcp packet
right which is going to give information
on things like the ordering of packets
and and some acknowledgement that things
have been received and then above this
is going to be an ip packet which is
going to have the destination
and where it's going and where it's come
from and things like this and then
you've got ethernet frames
right at the bottom which are very close
to proximity hardware stuff
if you want to add encryption to this
setup there's a question of the way you
put it right because things like ipsec
already exist so we can already encrypt
ip packets
right and this kind of existed already
but then you
if you do that then you have um
questions over you know do all the
routers support this and you've got to
set up routers
it's it's not as end-to-end as you might
imagine so that's one that's one option
but it's not it's not for everyone
another option is just to encrypt the
http itself so maybe you come up with
some protocol which is like an encrypted
version of http
which is the same but also now some of
the data is encrypted in some way
right um and that the benefit of that is
that then there's the web servers and
the browsers can control this so that's
good
but the downside is that it doesn't work
on anything other than http
right actually quite a lot of the
internet traffic is not web it's other
things
you know tor for example uses tls
doesn't use http
so what was decided what seemed like a
good idea
and this is where sort of ssl came from
or secure sockets layer
is to put the encryption between these
two things above tcp but below
the actual application that's running as
i recall we draw this as a stack
we talk about it as a stack but in
reality it's sort of things
in other things i seem to remember doing
an animation about envelopes where one
goes inside another goes inside another
yeah that's exactly what it is right you
have your http data or some other
application data here
and that's going to be its own size with
its own information in it
we don't care what that is in some sense
and this goes
with a tcp header which is going to add
some information
and then we have an ip header here and
then we have an ethernet
frame here which has a little bit of a
checksum at the end as well so they kind
of wrap each other like this
and what we're proposing to do here is
add another header
in here which is going to be where our
tls
information is held and then of course
this information will be encrypted
that's the idea and so as far as tcp and
ip and ethernet are concerned
they don't know that the information is
encrypted because they're not interested
that's just their payload they're
shipping off
so that's you know nice and handy so
this was a design
principle for this in about 1994 some
some researchers in
netscape developed ssl one so
they put it in between tcp and http so
it has nothing to do with http
in some sense and it has very little to
do with tcp apart from it relies on the
fact that tcp reorders packets correctly
right because obviously decryption
doesn't work so well if you mix
everything up
um and it was very basic this was
it was a start right now the problem
with ssl one was
that it had um loads and loads of bugs
right it used a stream cipher
but it didn't have any kind of mechanism
to prevent alteration of the packets and
things like this
it used only a simple checksum it didn't
have any sequence numbers
so the replay attacks happened a lot
so it you know it wasn't it wasn't ideal
it was only internal it was never
actually deployed
on the web so very quickly
this was sort of ironed out and they and
they came up with secure socket layer
2. this was about at the end of 1994
somewhere around this area
and um and this replaces the simple
checksum with a slightly better md5
construction
we know now that md5 has some problems
back then it was fine
you know at least we didn't know it
wasn't fine netscape actually patented
this in 1995
um not with a view to selling it but
with a view to stop other people
patenting it so they could release it
for free right which you know admirable
right not not all companies at this time
were operating in that way should we say
in 1995 internet explorer was released
right it's hard to imagine a time when
internet explorer didn't
um generate headlines and didn't exist
but it actually didn't exist until 1995.
microsoft saw the rise of things like
netscape and thought we need to get in
on this web game
so microsoft released this or just
designed alongside internet explorer
this rival technology called pct or
private communications technology
very similar to ssl in some sense so
similar
it's a bit suspicious but so similar
that it was almost interoperable which
which did make it easier for browsers
theoretically and web servers to support
this
but as with all of these things if you
have multiple things that do the same
function eventually you're going to have
to come together and solve that problem
right because it's just a bit silly
in november 1996 then ssl 3
was released right which was the much
improved version of ssl 2 and had some
actually incorporated technology from
pct in it as well
this was still netscape at this time
this was obviously not going to work
long term with multiple technologies all
doing exactly the same thing
so um the internet engineering task
force said right let's let's create a
working group for this
we'll call it the tier transport layer
security working group the tls working
group
and we'll basically make a new version
of this that will actually be a standard
and maybe we'll all just use the same
one
that seems to make a lot of sense um it
was renamed from
ssl to tls purely because microsoft
didn't want
netscape having dibs on the name
essentially
um okay fine all right um
you know i i think microsoft's practice
is probably much improved by now right
but during the 90s obviously there's
quite a lot of stuff going on with
browser walls and things so you know
it's
quite heated this working group was
formed in 1996 actually took him until
about 1999 to get a proper release out
and that was tls1
right so transport layer security one
and basically this is very very similar
to ssl miner
changes so in some sense it's sort of
spiritually we might say
ssl 3.1 and in fact actually the version
three one is sent in the header for tls
one
what's really improved over time is bugs
have been found
protocol issues various attacks and
things have been ironed out
and actually now it's really quite
impressive
you know the sort of security and
robustness you get from this
you know it's quite difficult to
intercept and fiddle around with
someone's traffic
so how does it actually work then yeah
um
i mean that's what everyone wants to
know right i mean i've spoken at length
now about how it became to be without
actually talking
have the history lesson right yeah yeah
sorry i went where's the tactic i got
carried away
all right um so what we have what we
want to do is we want to have
some kind of it's a cryptographic
protocol that exists
between two parties and they have to
agree certain things
and they have to follow certain rules
about message structure and things like
this
if this bike has to be here and this
bike has to be here in this order and
things like this
the idea being that you can use it to
very quickly establish encryption
and then use that encryption to bury
things like http
so everyone thinks about this in terms
of https
but actually has very little to do with
http it's actually just a
cryptographic protocol that sits on top
of tcp and can be used for anything
right so loads of inter application
communication will take place over tls
and won't go anywhere near http messages
right so
i think that's that was an important
part of the design process
so there's a few things we need to do if
we want to have
um encrypted communication right so
tls said right i'll talk in general
about tls well pat's going in a
different video go into detail about how
the handshake works i think that would
be quite
quite interesting um but
in general what we want to do is we want
to work out what ciphers
are we going to use because if you can't
agree on which encryption algorithm
you're going to use
you're not going to understand each
other's messages is it agnostic to the
kind of concretion
yes and no there are certain certain
versions of tls support certain ciphers
so as long as you and the server or you
and the other party
at least have one of those in common
you're going to be able to communicate
right so if i only talk aes and you only
talk char chart that's going to be a
problem but as long as one of us speaks
the other one it's fine
which ciphers are used have changed over
the years because some of the older ones
are no longer seen as
secure and we have more modern aead
encryption and things like this that we
use now
right but you know that's the idea but
it is meant to be interoperable
and one key part of this is that you
know if i write my tls client in
in let's say java and you write yours in
c plus they should be able to talk
because the message structure is fixed
right it doesn't matter who sent it
and so actually that's the case right
you go and you'll talk to a web server
programmed in some other language that
you
your browser doesn't doesn't know about
it doesn't matter right it's just about
the message structure
so what ciphers are we going to use then
we need to have some kind of secret key
so you know we're going to do some kind
of key exchange maybe to establish some
kind of secret key
or some other key material like keys for
use with mesh authentication codes and
things
we need some kind of authentication
right so
now authentication means we need to
demonstrate that at least
one of the parties is who they claim to
be right now richard talked about this
in his video it's very very important
because if you don't have this then of
course i send tls messages the whole
point is they're interoperable right so
some of some attacker could also
interoperate themselves let's say nicely
into the middle of the conversation
so it's very important usually with the
server sometimes a client as well but
usually but the server is authenticated
and this is going to involve public key
right so this is going to be public key
cryptography the server is going to have
to
resign some digital signature and you're
going to back this up with a certificate
and things like this
the last thing this needs to do is it
needs to be very robust right
robust to things like man in the middle
attacks
replay attacks where i just send the
same messages over again and try and
trick someone who's doing the same thing
twice or something like that
you know downgrade attacks where you try
and trick
a couple of people having a conversation
into using let's say weak ciphers or
something like this or weak keys
and various other possible attacks right
and it has to do all this within just a
few messages at the start of every
conversation
because of course if it takes 10 minutes
to establish this no one's going to do
this
right it has to be super super quick and
in fact as an example tls 1.2
does this with two round trips so client
to server
and back and server and back and then
it's done right
so it's pretty cool are there any other
things used instead of tls or is this
become
no no tns has become by far the most
used for this
right because it sits nicely in this
point between the applications and the
tcp stack
like ip security is used a lot for you
know vpns and things because it makes a
lot of sense at that low level but you
don't tend to see it so much for sort of
just
quick end-to-end encryption right and
again we see tls
all over the place in other net other
applications that are not
um but are not web-based necessarily so
you know most of your instant messages
will use tls to secure their
communication to the server
because why wouldn't they do that you
know um so
it's hugely prevalent it's really
important um and
it's very very clever but it can do all
of these things in just a few messages
and i guess we'll talk about that in the
next video does it ever go wrong
yeah all the time well what happens if
it goes wrong what's what's the user
experience there okay so i mean
the the most of a time when you go to a
website where something's gone wrong
with tls
is you'll see a big warning on your
screen probably because of a certificate
issue
right classically it's gone wrong
because they found attacks
not necessarily attacks that were
exploited in the wild on you know
consumers
but you know padding attacks and things
that needed to be fixed and have been
ironed out
and then of course you have
implementation problems like heart bleed
right which steve covered in a video
was a huge problem because everyone used
openssl
and that was a bug in their
implementation of tls which allowed
you to extract server ram right so you
know
often it's it's it's sometimes
approachable fault sometimes it's the
implementation of that protocol fault
but yes
plenty of things go wrong recently
slightly less
fingers crossed carry on copying for
another 65
528 worth of bytes now where those extra
bytes going to come from
or they're going to come from whatever
follows on in memory in the computer's
memory that's there
if we're lucky that data will be
meaningless so it's still just you
claiming to be whoever you claim to be
and i've got no other way of checking
that out which is why a lot of browsers